okay we are live
okay thanks fabiola welcome everybody to
the uh
public engagement board the
7th of april i'm george devlin and i've
agreed to chair the meeting
this morning and as we don't have
councillor weston or any of the councils
attending the meeting today
is there any apologies fabiola
hello sorry
just just sorry it's just one moment uh
chair i will we have a little issue with
uh
the youtube bear with me and i'll
resolve this straight away
and then we should be able to okay so we
should be fine now
thank you chair okay thank you
so do we have any apologies for today
uh i have received no apologies chair
thank you okay
and george apologies for interrupting
i'm not sure how to put my hand upon
this yet um sarah radcliff is having
difficulties accessing zoom i've just
mentioned it in the chat
um so if you can't attend i'll be
covering for sarah today
okay thank you rebecca um
just in terms of things doing sometimes
a bit complicated trying to put your
hand up electronically so i'm happy to
try and keep my eye open
for um real hands and the virtual screen
so is there any declarations of interest
minutes of the last meeting on the 24th
of march is everybody happy that their
accurate record
and i don't think there's any
matters arising that won't be on the
agenda
so item four is uh update on the current
situation in trafford
uh that be eleanor thanks
thank you george um so the current
situation in trafford is
that our rates um having gone up
slightly over the last couple of weeks
are now coming down again which
is very good news um but i think the
main message i
would have is that although our rates
are coming down we still have quite a
number of cases
and they're spread still across the
whole of trafford we've only got two
wards now with rates over 100 per
hundred thousand
but we're back in the position that we
were in in sort of middle of september
so we we haven't come down yet to the
figures that we had
last summer so i think it's just to to
remind
people that although we've we're having
great success with the vaccination
program
um with over 100 000 people vaccinated
so far and i know rebecca will talk more
about that
um and that is fantastic news that's
over 40 of our population
but covid is a very real risk still
people do need to be particularly
careful about any um
social activity particularly indoors and
we really do encourage people to stick
to the guidance and to stay outdoors
wherever you possibly can when you're
meeting people
in terms of our testing again we've
still got
really good access to the pcr testing
sites
and we really really strongly encourage
anyone who has symptoms to go for that
pcr test
um so although lateral flow testing is
being
more widely distributed and donna will
talk about that
if you have any symptoms it is the pcr
test that you need to
have it's not the lateral flow um so do
please do um remember that if you're
symptomatic the lateral flow is not the
suitable test to take
you should go for that pcr test um
i think we're all very excited about the
um
opening up of some of the hospitality
industry and shops and so on but again
it is that message that we're still not
out of the woods with covid
we really do need to be very very
cautious so
my main messages are thank you so much
to everybody who's been vaccinated
that's a fantastic thing you've done for
yourself that is the best way you can
protect yourself
your friends your families when go for
your second dose most the
doses being given in april will be those
second doses but if you're in the
cohorts one to nine that's if you're
over 50
if you're a carer if you're living with
somebody um who
is immuno suppressed so for example if
they're having chemo
and if you work in health and social
care fields and you've been invited to
vaccination please don't hesitate please
do go and get that vaccination now
because that is the best way that we can
protect ourselves
um i think that's probably all i want to
say at the moment
apart from a huge thank you to everybody
in trafford for for sticking with it i
just
i'm i'm so impressed by how well our
population has
has been keeping up keeping on keeping
on with this
um so congratulations all but we're
we need to keep going and actually these
next few weeks
are absolutely critical for making sure
that we um we do get on top of this and
i know
you know it's glorious sunshine but it's
freezing cold and it
don't you know if you had a plan to go
and see somebody outdoors but you think
it's too cold
please don't go and see them indoors
instead just wait on
um give it a few more weeks okay
thanks eleanor um is there any
questions any clarification that anybody
would like
[Music]
so i suppose the key message is um well
done
and keep it up for the next few weeks
and months and for
as long as it takes thank you yeah and
and to get your vaccination please don't
hesitate about vaccination
it is safe so please please do go
because
um i know people will be concerned about
the astrazeneca
but the covid is much more likely to
give you blood clots
and you're much more likely to catch
covert than to have any reaction to the
vaccine so
we would really really strongly
recommend that you take that vaccination
thank you on the item five
and the ten point plan it's uh update on
the mass
testing oh who's that donna
uh hi chair thank you very much yes um i
just wanted to um
alert um members to the um the new
universal
testing offer which was uh probably you
might have read about in the papers over
the weekend
or seen um in in the media
so um when i first started leading the
testing program i remember individually
just speaking to one person
about going for a test and now
thankfully and the testing offer
is being rolled out to a wide number of
people
and just as eleanor said the testing
program i'm going to talk to you about
very briefly
is around the lateral flow test but as a
reminder if you do have symptoms
go for your pcr test rather than a
lateral flow
lateral flow tests are for those people
who
perhaps unknowingly are transmitting the
virus
and for that reason lateral flow tests
are recommended
twice a week and the announcement now
is that there will be a universal offer
of lateral flow
from the 9th of april so rather than it
being restricted to key
personnel uh high-risk staff staff
working in certain settings
it's now going to be a universal offer
there are three ways chair that people
can access the tests
um firstly through the
direct email through the national
website so there's a national website
where you can go
and order and you'll get two sets of kit
which will last you for 14 tests
and in addition to that we have set up
now a community collect model
and that includes um the uh tests being
available at altering
them library cell waterside uh emston
library
and stratford library and also at
three of our community hubs in old
trafford
sale and in ermstan and all this
information will be available
on our council website and through our
other comms and social media
when the national communications come
about
and then the third way of accessing
those is through
um going to our asymptomatic testing
site
which as most of you will know is at
trafford town hall
um we are hopefully encouraging um
pharmacists
to also be part of the community collect
model um but pharmacies are coming on
at different stages in terms of the
rollout so
as soon as we know any trafford
pharmacist we'll include that on our
update and i think one of the challenges
that we found with testing
is that some people are reluctant to
test because of the implications of
self-isolation
and the financial implications so we
will be including lots of information
about the financial support that's
available and the eligibility criteria
for those people who have to
self-isolate
following a positive test so just
an update on that chair for you thanks
donna any questions any
clarification
no again i just think it's remarkable
how uh
how far we've come in terms of testing
you know we've now got mass testing kits
available for remember for everybody
from the 9th of july so
well done donna
the 9th of april 9th of april
thanks for that so the next part is the
contract
contact tracing and outbreak management
because um
is that hi it's it's me check thank you
um we haven't got a huge amount to
update you on from a contact chasing an
outbreak management perspective since
the last meeting
and the contact tracing
inbox continues to be there to support
our schools
um and complex settings and businesses
and we are also continuing
to proactively identify any businesses
and who may have had a small number of
cases and
offer them some proactive support but
other than that there's no further
updates from our last update at the last
meeting
okay thank you i just can i just add to
what it's really good news that we're
seeing fewer cases in the businesses and
so on and i think
um it's it's just reinforcing what kate
says
about um the learning we've had from
those businesses about how to keep
places
um secure and our environmental health
officers
have been doing a fantastic job um
working with businesses but i think as
as people as businesses start to open up
um
we do really need to make sure that all
of our businesses fully understand
um what it means to be covered secure
how to keep your workforce
for secure but also the importance of
getting trust from your workforce so
that if you do have a case that that's
reported
that people are able to be supported to
self-isolate and on the council website
there is the information about how you
can get how individuals can get support
to self-isolate if they need to either
support with things like shopping and so
on but also financial support
um but the other thing is that as as
workplaces open up again
people need to remember that actually
that general social mixing that may not
be actually
in the office or in the workplace but
around the workplace
actually adds risk um and to get that
trust with your staff so that they will
tell you that for example if they were
smoking in the smoking shelter
who else was in the shelter with them
because otherwise we we are in danger of
missing cases
because we know that covid is
asymptomatically transmitted
as well as um as some people remain
asymptomatic completely
other people are in fact you everybody
is infectious for those first
two days before they um before they
display any symptoms
so i think one of the things we all need
to be thinking about as people start
as as the economy starts opening up a
bit more we all need to be thinking all
the time about
you know if if we get covered symptoms
or forget covet thinking about what
what was i doing in the last five days
or so
where where might i have got this from
and what does that mean
and also who might i have infected so
who
are the people i've seen so it's it's
trying to make sure that we
we get that honesty and openness and
people are able to
say oh i think actually you know this
person this person has been a contact
because i think people have been very
cautious about naming
naming their contacts and i think we all
do now need to really take
responsibility
for thinking about how do we both let
people know
that they've been a contact and you know
if they're people we know
we have a duty to tell them ourselves
rather than just
um via track and trace but also trying
to make sure that we
we get really good engagement with the
track and trace
and where there are financial
implications that people
get good advice and the posted to that
it's all on the council website so i
really do recommend people have a look
at the council website about the
eligibility criteria
and those eligible if you are eligible
it would be
paid once you've had that positive
confirmation from a pcr
test so i think it's just just trying to
remind everybody
that actually if you see if you're back
in work and you see something that you
feel uncomfortable with
you know have that conversation with
your manager if you need to if you have
if you feel you can't have the
conversation with your manager
come to us at the council and the
environmental health team will give
advice as well
so it's just really and if you are a
manager and you see behaviors that you
think
aren't right you know we need to show
that leadership and have those
conversations with people in the
workplace
about making sure that we are all doing
everything we can to stop the spread
i think sorry and just to add a little
bit further we are
um it's that proactive work that we're
really pushing forward with our
businesses at the moment
making sure that they are covered secure
ready for the workplaces to come back
making sure that they are promoting
testing amongst their
the asymptomatic testing programs
amongst their workforce
um and and and just making sure that we
can offer support we've we've had
a couple of outbreaks in in local
businesses where we've been able to
support them with case finding testing
as well
and which the businesses have hugely
supported so it's
we're working really closely um
with our regulatory services
you know our economic resilience all
around those
messages about what support is available
because i think when we have approached
some businesses
you know they've been really really
happy with the support package we've
been able to offer them
great thanks for that kate dorothy did
you have a
question yeah it was it was just a point
about um
businesses and knowing who you're in
touch with
you know we're not promoting the um the
app that actually encourages people to
sign up to the app so that from a
business perspective you're not always
having to
ensure that people maybe have are using
the app so that if you don't know who
they are they
they can't be out people can be
identified
another way of um you know yeah that's
that's a really valid point thank you
and and we are
promoting that it it's that whole sort
of package of support that when we're
we're talking to businesses we're making
sure that they've got
you know the signage around the qr code
so people are signing in and out of
their their facility
and talking to them about use of all of
the things that can help them keep their
businesses safe
right okay so that dorothy
[Music]
one of the things for the public
engagement boards that i'd really like
um the members of the board to help us
with
is thinking about and i know nigel will
talk about this as well
it's just thinking about how do we get
messages like this out into the
businesses we've got routes to
businesses but actually the staff in the
businesses we don't always have the
roots too
but also the general public it's you
know the role of the vcsc is
so powerful in getting some of these
messages into communities
so i think what would be really helpful
from our point of view
is thinking about what are the messages
that you hear from your communities
and the people you work with and how do
we make sure that the messages that they
get are the correct messages
and that they're there and if there are
barriers for example that people have
how do we
how do we work to overcome those
barriers so the more information we can
get back from you
about what it's like and what it feels
like to the people you're speaking to
the better we can make sure that our
communications and our support
is tailored appropriately so it really
is
i think we we we need your help with
this because
this isn't something that can be done
top down we need to make sure that
um people in the communities are able to
have their voices heard on all of this
that we react appropriately thanks to
that eleanor
calm
um yes sir i just want to come come back
on that one
we've got from the bam communities we've
got a number of volunteers
who've been going down to uh small
businesses
uh the shops and so on and talking to
the
um to the owners and also people
actually coming in
to take precautions and i think a lot of
work has been done
by these volunteers uh they're putting a
lot of their time into that
and i think we want to take this
opportunity to thank all those
volunteers as well
yeah thanks a lot thanks thanks for that
cam
[Music]
so if we move into um mass vaccination
update is that rebecca
it is thank you chair um so i think
helen has very eloquently um
stated obviously the um key message
which is to encourage
uptake of the vaccine um as soon as
offered
um in terms of update i think i reported
last time we know that april
is um a slower month in terms of the
restricted
astrazeneca supply and so this week we
have had no
um astrazeneca first dose deliveries
however
um the uptake as ellen mentioned we've
done over 94 000 first ocs across
trafford and that
goes to above 100 000 when you can't
count the second doses as well
and second dose uptake is good we are
seeing slightly more hesitancy um
in terms of uptake of second dose
because of the reasons already um
identified today but um on good friday
and i know that two of the networks
second dosed um over a thousand
patients each so that's um an
exceptional achievement in
in one day and over a bank holiday as
well um so
as elena mentioned this is to keep the
message when offered the vaccine
take up the vaccine and there is no
choice in vaccines available still um
and obviously we're starting to see
potentially the impact of some of the
media messaging but the
the message hasn't changed and i know
nigel's on the call but again just in
terms of the community engagement work
we are starting to see a real impact in
terms of vaccine hesitancy that was
previously um
identified particularly in the north of
the borough and with
um i know uh nikki mentioned on a call
yesterday that there were 70 people
identified who had previously declined
who took up the vaccine over the weekend
so we are starting to see
an impact in in certain populations and
clearly the main priority at the moment
is planning for the next phase once the
supply allows which is cohorts 10 to 12
so the wider adult population
and that does present some different
challenges in terms of hesitancy
so um generally national feedback has
been that there is some more hesitancy
in younger people
and that population um is more
widespread
and so the ability to contact and bring
into local sites is perhaps impacted
and so very closely working with the gm
system on the
um mass vaccination sites as well to
support that population
and that's probably it from me yeah i'm
rebecca thank you is there any questions
anybody
need anything no
again i suppose it's just reinforcing
that message to have the vaccination
covert is more dangerous than the side
effects so
thank you nigel you're going to give an
update from the community engagement
team
sam thank you chair so first first thing
to say
is uh in terms of the the team itself uh
we've got some really
exciting news and that we've now
recruited to for
neighborhood engagement officers who are
on fixed term contracts for for six
months with us so um two of them started
last week two this week so that'll give
us
um no real additional capacity and uh
hopefully do some more engagement on the
ground particularly as we start coming
out of
various restrictions uh tackling vaccine
confidence
continues to be a big priority for the
team
this this work is coordinated through uh
weekly meetings that we have firstly uh
an operational group which is led by the
ccg and then an internal meeting where
we kind of review our actions
and what we're seeing as rebecca
mentioned is that through a combination
of the
various community engagement work we're
doing and the pop-up clinics this is
you know encouraging more residents to
take up their vaccination
by promoting confidence in the vaccine
and removing the various barriers that
there could be
so that includes clinics that we've had
for example in community settings such
as the limelight health and
wellbeing hub where the team are
continuing to support
and the volunteer offer there in terms
of uh vaccination confidence as well
just really want to thank the voice of
bme for all the work that they're doing
so as we've mentioned before they're
they're located uh
in practices within the north for the
borough and of our experience of making
calls to people and having conversations
with them so they'll be talking to
patients around their thoughts and
concerns around the vaccinations where
they've been initially reluctant
and as rebecca mentioned the latest
information we have
is that um 70 patients have now
changed their minds after speaking to
the voice of bme and have decided to
take the vaccination so that is really
really positive news
and also what we get from those calls is
some qualitative data as well
information
from those conversations around the
reasons for vaccine hesitancy which then
helps us to
deliver and develop our strategy going
forwards
so uh the next thing that we're looking
to do
and i mentioned this previously is
around um
putting together a door knocking program
so when we nearly finalized the plans
for this so
this is going to kind of build on those
that one-to-one approach
uh those phone calls which i mentioned
which voice of bme are
doing and it's going to be conversations
with people
individual households in areas where as
led by the data
where we're going to be able to promote
the local vaccination clinics uh listen
to concerns
issues that people have it's an
opportunity to give our messaging
provide reassurance
and if people need additional sign
support we can sign post them in that
direction
and if people would like a phone call
then we'll link back to uh voice of vme
so we're planning to do this work in a
couple of areas in the north initially
to pilot it
in the old trafford area and in uh and
in stratford where we've seen
a cluster of cases and another
uh issue that we're looking at is um
vaccination of uh homelessness
and close and rough sleeping as well so
we're looking working with colleagues at
host and john ambulance
that's coming up with a solution on this
in terms of um the volunteer
coordinators
we have uh set up the first um
forum where we've got the various
volunteer coordinators
and hub coordinators together so the
first meeting was
last thursday i think that went very
well
and what we're seeing that this this
meeting will do is an opportunity for
the various
um coordinators to come together share
good practice
discuss challenges and feedback uh in
you know in a supportive network
and just it offers you know an
opportunity to
to um for everyone to share feedback and
um in terms of the clinics going forward
and learn from best practice so
like i say the first meeting was last
thursday and it was well attended and
well supported
by those that attended and
uh the last couple things i just wanted
to talk about first of all the community
champions program
um you may recall that we were
successful in getting some funding
from mhclg for community champions
program to support people
shown to be most at risk from kobit 19.
so we've been looking at best practice
from other local authorities and we're
now ready to launch the first phase of
this programme
where we'll be looking to recruit
community champions who'll be able to
share uh advice around kobit 19
and other essential messaging and
information with their other
with their community contacts and
networks including for example advice on
the vaccinations reinforcing the
hands-faced space
compliance uh information about testing
isolation support and advice
but we also see this is an opportunity
for us to get uh
insights and information back in so we
really want to encourage that two-way
communication so we've developed a
website where the champions can sign up
and receive a welcome pack we're gonna
have a welcome video on there as well
from from eleanor
and we're looking to launch this uh
later in april
probably the weekend entertaining the
19th of april and we're just
looking at putting together a comms plan
now to support this
the champions will also get varying
support through um
fortnightly check-ins first of all with
the public health team
and also with the uh community
engagement team so that'll be an
opportunity for the champions to get
latest information
and for us to get feedback and uh views
and opinions from the champions so
although these champions are initially
being recruited to uh
focus on kobit 19 uh we see in the
longer term
that the role of the champions will
develop and they can then be ambassadors
for other wider issues
and just finally one other thing i
wanted to mention was around our
volunteer officer so we have uh
advertised for that role and we are
interviewing next week
so we've had a number of applications
for that so that's be really positive
we'll hopefully have something post soon
and that'll be somebody that will be
working for us for um
the next six to twelve months that will
really help to coordinate that volunteer
offer
particularly around vaccination clinics
but will also have a role in supporting
the community champion
so that's just an overview for me in
terms of some of the key activities that
we've been
taking over the last couple of weeks
thank you thank you thanks for that
nigel's very thorough sounds like
there's a lot going on
is there any questions anybody got for
nigel
nope okay
the next item's the um sorry george it's
not so much
question but it's just really a
congratulations to nigel and the team
for the work they've done but also um
thinking
again it's a question to pcse colleagues
about thinking
how how the work of this team can
support support you with your work
not only in covid but also about that um
recovery phase
and thinking particularly about how the
health and social care
world recovers um and i'm sure sarah
and others on the call will have will
have thoughts about how
how the learning from the covert
engagement feeds into learning for how
we make sure that people
um as as health services get built back
that we
build them back and reduce inequalities
while we do that because we do know that
um many of the issues for with covet
obviously have
have um have had an inequalities
dimension and we need to make sure that
as our services build back we
we uh plan out inequalities rather than
allow
inequalities to continue so and i think
there may be some really useful pieces
of learning
between the vcsc nigel's team and
particularly the ccg
in that in that building back and
recovery phase
i think just a quick bit of feedback on
that eleanor we're meeting with nigel
and his team tomorrow from the vcse
from the trafford community collective
and we have regular
representation feedback into the
strategic design group from nigel and
his time
team so i think we've you know we've got
the foundation
to learn and build on what everybody's
doing so far thanks
so updating your escalations from the
community enforcement team
excuse me
yeah um so apologies i've been on leave
for a couple of weeks
so playing catch up since yesterday and
in terms of the amounts of complaints
in relation to residential breaches they
have
um almost disappeared to nothing at the
moment
very very low numbers coming through
towards
and there's been a rewriting of the
letter that normally goes out to reflect
the changing
rules for people and
and we're only kind of picking up ones
that are more clear-cut in terms of
breaches
the focus at the moment really is on the
kind of reopening
of licensed premises in our town centres
so we've been doing quite a lot of work
around that so our licensing
team have written out to all the
licensed premises
to get an understanding of who is going
to be open
and what their plans and and processes
are going to be
for that and then we've had a team on
over the last couple of weeks
who have actually been ringing around
because he asked people to complete an
online survey well obviously not
everybody
does that when they receive a letter
through the post so they've been
ringing around so we've got over 90
responses
is quite um a mix in terms of who's
planning on
opening so those that have got quite a
lot of outdoor space and more inclined
to open
than those who haven't some are actually
gonna wait
until may and when hopefully the indoor
hospitality will reopen so they're going
to hold fire till then
and so we've got a better understanding
of that now
obviously some of the licensed premises
are applying for
pavement licenses and so they can put
tables and chairs
outside and we're giving advice in
relation to that
and what we're going to do is and have
staff both from great manchester police
and from our teams within the local
authority and also
one of our external security contractors
are going to just be out and about
um on the first couple of weekends of
reopening just to see how it goes into
this
staff on hand and should there be any
kind of issues and they're also there to
to answer any queries that people may
have so
kind of watch and wait at this point we
don't quite know how it's going to go i
think probably
whether dependent if it's nice weather
and people are inclined to go to beer
gardens and there might be more people
out
it's obviously less concern about you
know country pubs with huge kind of beer
gardens than there is in terms of what
might happen
in the town centre if lots and lots of
people descend and also not all of the
premises will be open and how that's
going to be managed so
um i think a busy couple of weeks ahead
for us but
we're all prepared for it
any questions from anyone
no it doesn't look like it thanks for
the update helen
and as you say next few weeks will be
interesting
so the next item is just any feedback an
update on
activity from members of the board
yup can
well there's no i'm not about any
activity but i think at the next meeting
um i would prefer to have a report on
uh some of these people arriving from
the red list countries
into our collaboration and
we do know that quite a few people from
trafford have traveled abroad
and they will be coming from those some
of those countries
and what information can we actually get
about how many people there are what the
status is and so on
so if the next meeting we can have that
information please
yes we can we could um there's some
greater manchester work being done on
this at the moment
so um obviously with particularly with
pakistan being added to the redless
country
list and we've got a lot of british
nationals um with family in pakistan
so some of whom may be there at the
moment
and obviously the changes to the
quarantine um
could be quite difficult for some
families because it does add an awful
lot of cost
so i think the main messages we would
have is
i know some families will be aiming to
be coming back
before the 9th when it takes effect
and it's really the main messages i give
is please do make sure you abide by the
quarantine
rules when you come back so even if
you're not in that hotel you must
self-isolate at home for those
for those two weeks when you come back
the reason for countries being added to
the red list
is mainly because of the south african
variant
and we really do not want that variant
um taking off in this country
so that that's the reason that these
countries have been added to the list
um and that that that is a you know it
does
give a very real threat to us so
um the other side of it is obviously
um if your families decide to stay
longer in pakistan
it's i think one of the things will be
making sure that any children
get good access to schooling and that
they're able to access
um stay on the school rolls and access
education from from the school that
they're in here
um while they're while they're away so i
think there may be
there is some work going on at greater
manchester level on all of this and
we'll be very happy to report back on
that but i think a message back into our
local communities
is um the main message back at the
moment is just making sure that people
understand the importance of the
self-isolation when when you get back
that that is absolutely critical because
the rates in pakistan
are high and they're high with this
south african variant that we
we need to make sure um doesn't doesn't
get a foothold in this country
well thank you i think one of the issues
in pakistan is
the introduction of the british variant
absolutely
which is interesting but also remember
many people are actually
trying to get back and because of the
limited number of flights they cannot
actually get their tickets to come back
in time
so there will be families coming in uh
who will
who will have to be quarantined uh but
people who can actually afford to stay
there they will stay for another few
months
and come back after the summer thank you
absolutely and i'm sorry i didn't mean
to imply that
um obviously the um the variant that's
um very
much spread across europe at the moment
is the british variant so
um i i apologize for using actually any
any
country term with this we should use the
numbers of the variants
um rather than um allowing different
countries to be
to be named but the um the dominant
strain at the moment that we have
in the uk is one that responds very well
to the vaccination
and it's just making sure that we um
that
we keep an eye on and and this country
is very very good at the genomic
sequencing so we're one of the best at
the world in actually understanding
which
which variants are circulating but
absolutely um absolutely
uh one of the greatest british exports
at the moment has been
the the new variant so i wasn't i wasn't
intending
anything um pejorative none of us can
none of us can really control which
which variant we get all we can make
sure of
is that we do everything we can to uh
make sure that
if we have any symptoms we take a test
and that we self-isolate
right chair it's uh sean it's even great
to manchester police can i just
touch on the quarantine subjects if
that's that's okay
yeah of course you can sean yeah it's
just to share with the members and
obviously around the public that um we
are getting
the information through from the border
force in terms of people in traffic that
are
currency and we are when appropriate
making those checks
uh which i think is really important
because the vast majority of people
traffic abiding by
the core would rules um and we just need
to make sure that we're doing everything
we can to try and support that
so it was just to give you a bit of
reassurance that there is some checks
being done as well
uh around the quarantine side of things
that's great that's really helpful
thanks john
again it's just to reiterate i think our
thanks to our various communities who
are taking it really seriously and are
are self-isolating as requested so um
it's just it uh it's uh making sure that
people understand that we recognize
how difficult it is there are um and i
don't know
kate or helen there's a new there's some
new guidance on 10
that's coming out from greater
manchester on ten ways
to spend your ten days um which will be
circulators as well to try and support
people with that
um self-isolation and there's lots
online as well about how to take
exercise while you're
while you're in you know while you're
self isolating and so on
so so again on the council website there
are lots of links to this and there will
be more information coming out
but again it's it's mainly to say thank
you to everybody because we recognize
how hard people are working
on that self-isolation how difficult it
is and what a fantastic job people from
all of our communities are doing
to abide by those rules
thanks eleanor is there any other
business
yeah so i think it's just to echo that
thanks
to everybody on the board and to
everybody who's making such a
fantastic effort to manage and control
the virus
the next meeting is planned for the 5th
of may the 21st of april chair
through you thank you wow
oh ok 21st of april next meeting is
planned
so hopefully see everybody then
enjoy the rest of the day if there's no
other business we'll close the meeting
thank you
thank you